where is the same Iman Norway Masjid I
can't see it where is it okay relax
relax alhamdulillah we've purchased this
huge 2 700 square meters building with
this huge 7.5
000 square meters of land and
Insha'Allah with your help we are going
to convert this huge property into the
most epic Islamic Center in the whole
country of Norway and this is not one of
those one of agile projects where you
give your sadaka and you get the reward
for that one specific deed that you
donated towards now this is a
sadakajaria that will keep on giving you
rewards for as long as this Masjid
stands click the button to donate
whatever you can
isn't it important how you aren't
portraying yourself now
[Music]
wanna seek Redemption it's not about
anything else it's got nothing to do
with you no thanks
you're not making me feel
[Music]
foreign
top of me and then he stopped himself I
know how I broke down people are you at
peace with yourself right now
[Music]
I refer to myself as a monster actually
I was no excuse me there was no excuse
no I was I was like if I said I was
online because I never used to drink
alcohol what I mean who was it like what
me I don't know
[Music]
just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years what
is one thing that they would carry with
them the Quran why because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets brothers and sisters imagine you
have a app the qurani app which not only
shows you how much rewards you get but
reminds you to read the Quran gives you
reminders app now and let it testify for
you on your makayama that you read it
wherever you was